the man who is gonna launch a new series
identify launching a new series called
next level behind Baker at docu-series
following the 2017 Heisman Trophy winner
Baker Mayfield how you doing Matt Reed
good how are you I'm doing just fine
where have we caught you I am in the car
right now gonna grab some lunch and then
in just a little bit I'll be headed
almost in my second camped youth camp
today okay so what what are you doing
with the kids just doing some drills
some fundamental work yes they had about
250 plus and had stations set up and we
rotate around it some some drills and
had some fun with the kids okay and then
no what are you getting for lunch and be
careful everything is evaluated this
time of year Baker what are you getting
for lunch so healthy smoothie probably
going to be green okay with with
probably a like an egg white flatbread
I'm feeling breakfast stuff right now I
know why oh come on a real avocado crave
I think it's because I've been living in
California too long is that right or is
that the T b12 method are you doing that
thing with the avocado ice cream and all
that business I guess you got to go you
got to get to the pros first before you
before you do all that what is the
craziest evaluation of you that you've
heard so far probably calling cowards
511 quarterbacks thing what does that
ring I measured it he said I was 511
when there's a standard I'd you know
measurement for me that I'm not so I
don't know there's a bunch of different
stuff going around you hear everything
but it's this whole process is its
revealing of how people think some
people think about the game of football
and winning and then some focus on the
stuff that doesn't really matter right
and in terms of the stuff that doesn't
really matter what would you what would
you say doesn't matter from what you
were hearing from what you want people
to say what do you put in the category
of does not matter cool a bunch hand
size would be one okay
I think you know I mean it's probably
pretty much all the measurables it now
that I'm thinking about it so I mean you
can you can put stuff down on a piece of
paper but when you and you go out there
and play the game and you got guys
running at you that's when it really
shows so you know I think throwing on
air at the combine but only at pro day
it's all good to see if you can actually
throw the ball but until you put a
defense in front of you and have that on
tape and I don't think any of those
stuff matters yeah I mean and all the
other stuff you know I was discussing it
the other day on the show here Baker's
when you were asked about you know how
how things have changed maybe your stock
or something like that you say your
stock has risen you were third or fourth
round draft grade before the season
where you are now and that you you know
consider yourself the best in the class
and people all there's Baker may feel
being cocky again and my thought is like
what how the hell are you supposed to
answer that question you know what am I
supposed to say no I don't believe in
myself you know but no you shouldn't
pick me because I think I'm bad yeah
because and I just feels that everything
you're doing is viewed the prism through
the prism of being cocky and there's a
it's the vision of people thinking that
I'm cocky but in reality you want a guy
that believes in themselves you want
that you want a guy that's gonna come in
and knows what he's doing
be confident about it because you go
into a locker room the NFL grown men
you can't be scared you can't can't
flinch about it you got to be able to go
in and do your job and it's a combine
did did anybody try to trigger you
during an interview at all absolutely
details but they may all try to do that
they'll they'll teach you a play and
then somebody in the background will
start asking questions about your
background like literally somebody
behind the scenes will start asking
questions about your background your
family history stuff like that and then
though then they'll jump into tape and
just see if you can
you know switch them from one subject to
the other and still still know the game
of football and how do you think he
handled that I think for me that was the
best part of the process that was where
I you know made the most improvement to
show that you know like I know the game
I love it and I've been able to get in
front of people and just talk about it
and be myself all doing that well you
see you saying that that that was the
best part of you doing that Baker I
think that's a little cocky you know am
I wrong I mean I don't know if I'm wrong
from a little bit off right there just
you know the company hey did you uh did
you ever hook up with Favre Brett Favre
and all the when you were on the show
last time and you just mentioned Favre
and and I I said that you know he really
liked the the way that you played the
games you guys ever connect we did we
did that was you guys connected that one
they sent his number over actually shot
me a text so it was uh was pretty
awesome honestly thank you no no I'm
just wondering if I could pry a little
bit to see what you guys communicated
about at all we didn't reinvent the
wheel okay so a couple more minutes here
with Baker Mayfield before he goes and
he gets his his egg white smoothie here
on the Rich Eisen show the pro day
attire the I guess the what we call a
headband a bandana again I'm a guy who
doesn't need to worry about hair getting
in the way what do we call that that you
wore for the protein okay the headband
have you ever seen the Karate Kid Baker
okay
is that what you were going I thought a
couple side-by-side taste yours okay
and what do you think pretty spot-on all
right so is that the look you were going
for were you trying to do that no I mean
did the headband in general
I didn't expect it to be put side by
side but you know the greatest garage so
who would you
would you equate yourself with more
Daniel sana or Cobra Kai Baker okay my
brother here - laughing would your
brother but what's your brother's name
so who would you think Baker is more of
Daniel son or Cobra Kai
[Music]
thank you your brother's trying to have
your back here he's trying to have your
back here okay Connor is he driving what
do we got here see that's Baker being
cocky won't let his brother sit up front
draft stock going down with each passing
second here so in all seriousness no
Baker there's a report in the mm QB that
you're being tailed that there's a
private investigator checking you out by
a team that might be interested in you
what what can you tell me about that not
too sure so but I mean that's you think
about it teams wanna you know they want
to see what they're gonna get out of a
guy because they talk about the first
round take around the minutes top three
rounds you're investing a whole lot
money and then guys but you know you
don't know on a personal level so I can
believe that
but at the same time that hopefully if
there is one it'll answer all the
questions of people thinking that I'm
just I don't do anything besides party
in football so hopefully it'll show that
you know folks ready to go so you don't
take it personally no I mean I look at
it as if this is a you know a chance to
improve on every everybody's you know
envisions on me and I can show the right
things okay so what's next for you
after obviously
today do you have any personal meetings
set up yet I need any any teams knock on
your door yet Baker I had a couple
meetings here in Norman and then I have
a few set up next week
you got a drop in English we got to get
names I got to get names come on give me
links what do you got
the Chargers in the Giants already then
I got the bills Saints Browns Dolphins
Jets I think that's it for here and then
I then I started visiting in April okay
Wow all right so those are the people
who met with you there you know and then
in Norman if I haven't already met that
I will be meeting yes here in Norman
okay man Saints that's an interesting
one right out there I look I know you
can't talk about which one you want you
just want to be there and do you have
your suit picked out yet for a for Iliad
for the draft my my full breath Marvin
wear jean shorts you're not going to the
draft you're not gonna be there no I'm
gonna hang out with the family there's a
lot of people to help me get here so I'm
gonna enjoy it there and I think that's
the best way to do it okay so you're not
gonna go there is it gives it's in Texas
is that why is that what it is I know
that but I mean still I mean there's
still some people right that day
considering it isn't you know okay miles
didn't go to Jeff last year so Matt do
you Matt Matt do you do you agree that
Baker should not go to the draft so what
you're saying brother percent okay it's
a phrase that well there's a lot of
people that help them get there so you
know what here's using he's trying to
give himself some credit right here
here's the deal here's the deal
daniel-san would go to the draft Cobra
Kai would stay home that's it there you
go
hey Baker appreciate the time just you
know it so is there an unmarked
about about 30 feet behind you look in
the rearview mirror
is there anybody fan with no windows
all right Baker's be careful be careful
go go hang with the kids have a good
time and I hope to see you soon new guy
that's Baker Mayfield the Rich Eisen
show weekdays at noon eastern on
audience